I just want time to slow down this night
is perfect
mm-hmm but then we meet delaying the
best part the rest of our lives till
death do us part
[Music]
every card was a client at the dry
cleaners for some reason my card was the
client yeah weird what I did not
authorize or sign a check for my account
to be wiped clean
hello what are you doing who is she
she's my little sister Daisy you don't
think I rush to do this to you I think
if you have real concerns about your new
marriage you should speak up now before
stuff gets real your husband's away
Nyhus he's gonna ruin you how do you
even know me oh I know him because I'm
his wife leo is married to me and Sam is
married to me have you had any tenants
living here recently he wanted to get
married
I said yes he's my husband you and I
aren't the only women whose finances
he's try to get himself in control of
vandal Scott married four times in the
last five years
oh the man is a lunatic this isn't the
first woman he's killed
he's like a fox he's not sloppy he's
smart he's always two damn steps ahead
huh
do you think he ever loved any of us
making clothes
what are you doing you scared
you